Are we alone in the universe? Of all
of humanity’s most profound ponderings
whilst perched on porcelain thrones,
that one’s probably the biggest. It's
also one of the most difficult to answer. As
of today, nobody knows if Earth is a singular
oasis or simply one amongst countless
celestial sanctuaries harbouring life.
Despite this uncertainty, it's a question worth
asking. Because, for better or for worse, first
contact with an alien race would arguably be the
most important event in the entire 200,000-year
history of our species, surpassing even the
invention of the wheel or the discovery of fire.
The knowledge that there are other
intelligent species out there would
fundamentally change what it means to be human,
irrevocably altering our understanding of
both the universe and our place within it...
...But here's the thing. It
might have happened already.
And I’m not talking about some Area
51-government-conspiracy crap. I mean,
we may have already received an unambiguous
and well-documented message from the stars.
This is the story of the Wow! Signal -
mankind's first contact with aliens... maybe.
On the 15th of August 1977, Jerry
Ehman was sitting in his kitchen,
scrutinising a substantial stack of seemingly
senseless scribblings - each page was covered
in random numbers and letters as though someone
had sneezed on them while eating alphabet soup.
But, as a research scientist
with the SETI project,
Jerry Ehman's trained gaze could discern
this cosmic code. Because it was data
from one of the world's most powerful
radio telescopes, nicknamed Big Ear.
Unlike regular telescopes that use lenses
and mirrors to magnify visible light,
telescopes like Big Ear are designed to
gather radio signals originating in deep
space, and it was this info contained in
Jerry Ehman’s alphabetti spaghetti printouts.
Each of the 50 columns represented a different
frequency channel, and the numbers and letters
within those columns displayed the strength of
any incoming radio signals of that frequency.
Low numbers meant weak signals - background
noise mostly - and high numbers meant stronger
signals. The columns were only wide enough
for a single character, so signals above a
9 were assigned a letter (A meant a signal
strength of 10, B - 11 , C - 12 and so on).
Jerry had searched through literally
thousands of pages like these during
the 4 years Big Ear had been hunting
aliens, without finding anything of
particular interest. But on that fateful
day in 1977, his eye was drawn to a signal
that looked like nothing he'd never seen
before - 6EQUJ5 - an alphanumeric string
so startling that Jerry circled it in red pen
and scribbled the now famous 'Wow!' annotation.
The so-called Wow! signal had several attributes
that made it so remarkable. To start, it was a
staggering 30 times stronger than background
radio noise. It had also only registered in
one of Big Ear's 50 frequency channels, meaning
it was what we would call a narrow-band signal.
Narrow-band radio signals aren't typically made by
natural sources - they're generated by technology.
As soon as he saw the signal, Jerry
Ehman knew that he might be looking
at humanity’s first contact with
aliens. But as Carl Sagan once said,
extraordinary claims require extraordinary
evidence. The first thing the SETI team had
to do was make sure the Wow! Signal
really *was* something extraordinary.
Observing the universe through a radio telescope
is a notoriously finicky business for the simple
reason that radio waves are absolutely
bloody everywhere. A ceaseless cacophony
of cosmic clamour, including stars, black
holes, and quasars, constantly emit radio
waves like drunk gunslingers in an intergalactic
saloon. Closer to home, terrestrial technologies
also rely on radio waves, like TVs and
telephones, only compounding the chaos.
If anyone was going to take
the Wow! Signal seriously,
it had to be demonstrated that it hadn't
come from any of these other sources.
Galactic radio noise could be swiftly eliminated
because the Wow! Signal was far too strong. Other
natural phenomena like stars and quasars could
also be ruled out, because they emit radio
waves across a wide range of frequencies, not a
single narrow band. They also tend to emit them
constantly over millions, even billions of years,
but when Big Ear listened to that same section of
sky the following night, the mysterious signal
was gone. Finally, interference from earth-based
technology also seemed extremely unlikely. The
Wow! Signal traced an unmistakable bell-shaped
curve, matching the expected signature of
a space-based source passing directly over
the telescope. Earth-based interference, on the
other hand, typically produces sporadic pulses.
So, the signal was seemingly artificial and came
from the cosmos. That must mean it was aliens,
right? Well, not necessarily. The scientists
first had to confirm that the signal hadn't
come from our *own* radio wave-producing
space-based technology - satellites.
It didn't take them long. You see, in the
late 70s, fewer than 300 satellites orbited
earth - and none of them were supposed to be
nearby on the night in question. Moreover,
Big Ear’s data showed that the Wow! Signal’s
source was stationary relative to the stars.
In other words, to have produced the Wow! Signal,
one of the fewer than 300 satellites in existence,
would have to have been in exactly the right part
of the sky at exactly the right time, moving in
exactly the right direction at exactly the right
speed to match the motion of the stars around it.
In my book, that's pretty conclusive,
but the evidence against the
satellite theory doesn't stop there.
You see, it wasn't just the strength and signature
of the Wow! Signal that was so unusual - it was
also the frequency it was resonating at: 1420 MHZ.
That’s incredibly close to something called’’’
the hydrogen line, the frequency at which
hydrogen atoms naturally emit radio waves.
The significance of that seemingly
random coincidence might not be
immediately obvious, so let me explain.
Hydrogen - the cosmos’ most copious
element, is so abundant that sensitive
radio telescopes are able to detect its
perpetual radio hum everywhere. Thus,
tuning our telescopes to this particular
frequency unveils a wealth of knowledge
about the fabric of the universe. Succinctly put,
1420 MHZ is arguably the single most important
radio frequency for *any* young civilisation
seeking cosmic comprehension. Chances are,
if we’re listening to it, then so is
everyone else - for the very same reasons.
You probably know where I’m going with all
of this. Contacting a distant civilisation
across the boundless expanse of space is a
tricky business. There’s no way of knowing
what languages they speak, even what sense
organs they might possess… but the hydrogen
line is universal. Any alien wanting to be
heard would be wise to transmit at 1420 MHZ.
For this - and other - reasons, 1420 MHZ is
an internationally protected radio frequency
reserved solely for scientific research - nobody
else is allowed to use it. Going back to the
satellite theory for a second, to have produced
the Wow! Signal, not only would a satellite need
to have been in the right part of the sky at the
right time, moving in the right direction at the
right speed - it would need to have been
transmitting on an illegal frequency too.
It was clear the Wow! Signal wasn’t the
result of interference or misidentification,
nor a malfunction - the telescope was
tested thoroughly, and no issues were found,
plus it would have been a hell
of a coincidence if a random
instrumentation error perfectly replicated
the exact signal researchers were seeking.
So, to summarise. The Wow! Signal
was a narrow-band radio signal that,
so far as we know, must have been generated by
some kind of technology. It originated in space,
it wasn't the result of earth-based interference,
and it was sent on a very specific frequency
that we believe aliens might use to contact us.
All of this leads me to one pretty obvious
question. Why the fuck isn’t the Wow! Signal
considered to be the most important scientific
discovery in the history of the human race?
Well, that rather rude question has a very
simple answer: since that fateful day in 1977,
the Wow! Signal has never been detected again.
We've scoured the skies with far bigger and better
telescopes than Big Ear, but almost 50 years
on and there's been nothing. Not a whisper.
Until we verify the signal through a
second observation, doubts will linger
about its nature and origin. True, nobody has
provided a compelling (non-alien) explanation,
but that doesn't automatically mean there
isn't one. We may just have missed something,
or perhaps the signal was generated by
some kind of natural phenomenon we haven't
discovered yet. Without more data from further
observations, it's impossible to say for sure.
As the years pass without the return of
the Wow! Signal, doubt steadily seeps in.
After all, if this was the interstellar
equivalent of E.T. slipping into our DMs,
why suddenly cut the transmission?
It's also worth mentioning that Big Ear
detected no modulation of the signal,
meaning, so far as we can tell, there was no
actual information encoded within it. Again,
why? If an alien intelligence went to all the
trouble of getting in touch across the galaxy,
wouldn't it have made sense
to actually *say* something?
Almost 50 years on from the
detection of the WOW! Signal,
it continues to both fascinate and frustrate
the scientific community. Back in 2017,
an astronomer of somewhat dubious credentials
claimed to have traced the signal back to a couple
of previously uncatalogued comets enveloped
in radio wave-emitting hydrogen gas clouds.
Several astronomers (with significantly
more impressive credentials) soon pointed
out that the comets in question
wouldn't have been in the right
part of the sky when the Wow! Signal
was recorded, and even if they had been,
comets don't produce the right kind
of radio signals in the first place.
In short, it was a bust. But the fact the
story made headlines around the world shows
that people are still intrigued
by this most mysterious missive.
More recently, as we've begun to
map our galaxy in greater detail,
astronomers have attempted to pinpoint
the exact star system from which the
Wow! Signal might have originated. During
a 2020 survey, Spanish astronomer Alberto
Caballero identified 66 stars in the
Sagittarius constellation as possible
candidates. Work is already underway to
search these stars for signs of life.
Will we find an advanced civilization
orbiting one of them, wondering why
the hell it's taking us so long to reply to
their voicemail message? Only time will tell.
After recording the Wow! Signal, the Big
Ear telescope continued its search for
extraterrestrial life until 1995, making
it the longest-running SETI project ever
conducted. In the 22 years Big Ear patiently
listened to the radio wave whispers of the
universe, it never detected anything
remotely similar to the Wow! Signal,
which to this day remains one
of science's greatest enigmas.
Thanks for watching.